[Music]
drop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
Miles Morales he's entering sector four
do I uh have web on my face what's the
deal miles
black
let me guess he died
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you were supposed to
be here combined all right whatever
whatever wow whatever so are you like a
cow or a Dalmatian I am the spot
it's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
he's lying to you and I think you know
it
what's up danger
miles wanna get out of here oh when
Spiderman there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it who's the
new guy this is unbelievable this is the
lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's the guy gotta do to join
this spider team you can never be part
of it don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99
go easy on the kid he had a terrible
teacher Peter files you have a baby
I'll take it from here
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
to send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my
end let me guess he died
[Music]
thank you